le conseil de sécurité de l'onu s'est
réuni dans l'après midi pour évoquer les
tirs de missiles effectués par la corée
du nord hier soir et ce matin puis on y
engage procéder au tir de six missiles
de courte portée et d'un missile d'une
portée suffisante pour atteindre
l'alaska hawaï à la communauté
internationale dénonce une provocation
régis n'est ce pas les tirs ont eu lieu
la nuit dernière au moins sept missiles
balistiques dont un à longue portée
le tas est pas donc deux susceptibles de
frapper les côtes américaines en alaska
ou à hawaï
tous ces missiles se sont abîmés en mer
du japon provoquant la colère dans les
pays voisins comme ici à séoul où des
manifestants ont brûlé des drapeaux
nord-coréens à l'exception de la chine
qui reste prudente
les condamnations se sont multipliées
dans le monde la russie l'union
européenne mais aussi la corée du sud et
le japon qui ont annoncé des mesures de
rétorsion et des sanctions économiques
les etats-unis parlent de provocation
tout en affirmant vouloir privilégier la
diplomatie et la communauté
internationale dispose d'un certain
nombre de moyens aux noirs auraient pus
difficile pour la corée du nord de
s'engager dans une stratégie de la corde
raide très nude et de poursuivre son
programme d'armes nucléaires
un programme qui suscite l'inquiétude
isolé sur la scène internationale le
régime de pyongyang refuse depuis
novembre dernier de revenir à la table
des négociations
la corée du nord revendique son droit à
posséder l'armé nucléaire donc elle n'a
déclaré en 2002 elle déclare avoir des
bombes que personne n'a vu mais enfin
et elle considère qu'elle est habilitée
et qu'elle a le droit de posséder cette
arme de dissuasion contre la menace
américaine et pour défendre le régime
un régime mise en accusation aujourd'hui
devant le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies qui pourrait décider de
prendre des sanctions à l'encontre de la
corée du nord